я зараз знаходжуся в Амстердамі біля
аеропорту схід гол де винесли вирок у
справі mh17 нагадаю що ця справа
стосується
катастрофи літака міжнародних малайських
авіаліній та ця катастрофа відбулася у
небі над Донбасом 17 липня
2014 року суд визнав винний у вбивстві
298 осіб які знаходилися на борту
авіалайнера колишнього міністра оборони
самопроголошеної ДНР гіркіна
Сергія дубинського який йому підчинявся
та громадянин України Леоніда харченка
ще один підозрюваний Олег Булатов був
визнаний невинуватим тому що Суд не
знайшов достатньо доказів для того щоб
його обвинувати потрапити на суд було
дуже важко тому що у суді дуже невелика
кількість місць тому як ви бачите у
цьому призрумі було дуже багато
журналістів вони всі або майже всі
журналісти дивилися вирок тут на великих
екранах було дуже багато українців з
різних куточків було чутно українську
мову сфера в самому суді була дуже
напружена тому що
напередодні тобто перед судом Ми
поспілкувалися з рідними таблицькими
загиблих і вони казали що вони
відчувають себе дуже напружено вони не
знають що На що чекати але вже після
суду було видно багато щасливих облич
Чому вони були щасливі тому тому що
насправді зараз вже після цього вироку
Вони знають що
відбулося там у Донбасі 8 років тому
вони до сьогоднішнього моменту не знали
правду про це і зараз завдяки цьому
процесу завдяки суду їм все стало
зрозуміло і
завтра коли
опублікують оприлюднюють
довгу версію вироку її можна буде
прочитати в інтернеті вони будуть знати
ще більше що означає що означає цей
вирок Ну те що
принаймні
одна людина Тобто гірким який зараз
знаходиться як він каже на території
України
він є шанс що що його спіймають тому що
він на території України є шанс що його
приведуть до суду і що він буде
заарештований тому що цей вирок надає
можливість арештувати
усіх трьох
звинувачених у вбивстві вбивстві
пасажирів та екіпажу малазійських
авіалій звичайно
шанс того що його спіймають на території
України невеликі але він є тому що ми
знаємо я нагадаю що за його голову
об'явили винагороду і в Україні є багато
людей які дуже хочуть спіймати гіркина
Але у якій країні він буде відбувати
арешт ще не зрозуміло це може бути в
Україні але це може бути І у Нідерландах
тому що у Нідерландах Нідерланди
отримали юрисдикцію українці люди
знаходяться у міжнародному розшуку і
можуть бути теоретично заарештований
заарештовані у будь-який момент Але
звичайно якщо Гіркін знаходиться в
Україні то
є більше шансів що це дійсно відбудеться
тому що з приводу інших двох громадян
Росії
Якщо вони знаходяться у Росії а Росія
вже відреагувала на цей вирок і сказала
що вона його не приймає і що в ньому
немає Правди то звичайно Росія як вона
не співпрацювала зі слідством та кана не
буде і співпрацювати із судом і не буде
видавати
громадян незалежно від того який був цей
вирок питання про роль Росії у цій
справі дуже важливе тому що
постійно лунала
Росія Москва Росія Москва тобто Хто
стояв за координуванням та за бойовими
операціями на території Донбасу у 2014
році і суд казав дуже однозначно що це
була Москва вони побачили дуже багато
доказів у видів фото у вигляді фото у
вигляді аудіо у вигляді перехвачених
телефонних розмов де постійно
звинувачені тобто вже винні
розмовляли між собою про те що треба
спитати щось у Москви або що робити з
чорною скриньою після того як відбулася
катастрофа як вони збили
з бука літак малазійських авіаліній
Тобто Це звучало постійно і можна
сказати що у цього вердикті який
сьогодні
виніс суд біля амстердаму також
прозвучало що за цим вбивством стоїть
Росія дуже важливо наголосити що
сьогодні суд підкресли що
конфлікт на Донбасі у 2014 році був
міжнародним Чому Тому що Росія брала
безпосередню участь у цьому конфлікту
вона координувала дії сепаратистів вона
сама вела бойові дії на території
Донбасу
представляла зброю
сепаратистам тобто принаймні ці три
аргументи
привів суд для того щоб сказати що Росія
дійсно була стороною цього конфлікту